I made a talk to you about typescript
and specifically why I'm excited about
typescript and the reason I'm so excited
is because I used to be sort of against
typescript I used to be pretty much
against anything that wasn't like
vanilla JavaScript when you try to write
JavaScript but a little bit less than a
year ago we started pouring the slack
desktop application which runs on
electron and highly over to typescript
and we had a few a few reasons for that
and want to talk a little bit about what
we liked what we didn't like because
when we started on this journey I
couldn't really find all that much
information about what was good and what
was bad about it from people who
actually tried to port an application
over you found a few people like talking
very high-level about you know starting
with a new project but how do you
actually port an existing application
over and the the reason this is
interesting is because I always want to
motivate this a little bit right like
why do we care about improving
JavaScript as it is I actually think
that javascript is a lot more popular
than people realize
or no js' and maybe more popular than
people in this room realized and my two
favorite examples for that are always
the Nvidia drivers and the Adobe
Creative Suite both running nodejs
quick show of hands who knew yeah not
that many people so if you ever come
across any Windows computer that has
Nvidia drivers on it those computers are
running nodejs if you just open up any
application in the Creative Suite like
Photoshop or InDesign you're starting
nodejs and of course if you're running
any electron implication you know
something like Visual Studio code slack
atom github desktop now the list goes on
forever you're running ojs and in those
scenarios and that's the scenario I care
about and the scenario is JavaScript is
interfacing with native node modules and
those native node modules are likely
making system calls at some point
they're interacting with the operating
system so in my world and the world in
which I write JavaScript if I mess up
it's usually not a console error thing
and usually ends up summer and c++ blows
up and then my application is crashed
and because I'm running node on my
customers machine right we're shipping
the whole thing to customers it blows up
on the customers machine which is great
a terrible so on it's entirely the slug
experience people want so we got to make
sure that our code is structurally sound
and there's a there's a few solutions to
making sure your coda structurally
sounds I'm sure many of you have worked
with giant vanilla JavaScript code bases
the most obvious solution to checking
out what code does is to just read the
source code right if you're using
something like request and you're using
your request or get you wondering how
that works you could just like try to
find the source code for it
just grab for it figure out what get
does depending on how many dependencies
you have this might be difficult because
you actually got bucks to fix and
features to fix so just constantly
reading all your dependencies might be
somewhat tedious and sort of like
defeats the point of using dependencies
right you ideally just want to like know
what code does so then people come along
and write documentation as they should
but the trouble with J's talk Aeneas
talk internal documentation is that you
need to trust your fellow developer your
fellow developer needs to like document
stuff correctly and also needs to write
code that is correct and that is
increasingly difficult I at least feel
so if you've ever come across any
documentation that was slightly out of
date that is my biggest nightmare right
stuff is slightly out of just by like a
month breaks my application that's
pretty terrible for me so and summary
both methods don't really work for me
right they didn't really cut it so long
comes typescript obviously type goodness
types we're not gonna really talk about
that for too much time but I want to
quickly touch upon a few things that are
really liked about typescript the first
one is that it's a superset of
JavaScript meaning that javascript is
valid typescript that was a really big
deal I don't think enough people talk
about that it's a really big deal that
you can just like start coding
typescript throw in all this javascript
and don't really have to worry about
anything
it's just valid it just works anything
you can do in JavaScript you can do in
typescript and you don't really need to
turn anything into typescript in order
to run the typescript compiler against
it something I'm gonna talk about a
little bit in a minute and it's not just
that typescript accepts JavaScript just
fine it's also that typescript puts out
normal JavaScript there's no type script
that runs on runtime it has a few like
bubble-like features where does some
pretty cool polyfills but in general
typescript doesn't really do anything in
runtime which is important to me because
I don't really want some magic black box
that change is my code at runtime
and then two things that were really
important to us as a team that is
cross-platform right we built an
application for Windows Linux and Mac OS
typescript had excellent support for all
the editors so if you you know I want to
recommend a single editor but whenever
you're like next to a shouting match
about which editor is the best doesn't
matter
trafficking supports it right and like
if you really want to run the operating
system known as Emacs sure right type
kit will be there the same is true for
the NPM world and there's an application
that depends heavily on modules that you
find on NPM in that we use integration
with NPM is a really really important
point and I feel like at this point in
time if a module has definitions type
definitions available they're likely in
typescript the other interesting part is
that even if a module isn't written in
typescript of which there of course many
it's very likely that the community has
come in and written type definitions for
it we have live on something north of
3000 type definitions but even if all
those things aren't like the case and
you're using some obscure module that
somebody wrote ten years ago and it
doesn't have type definitions available
typescript is doing a really good job of
dealing with those modules so with that
said I think I want to like very quickly
jump in and just like show a second of
typescript just so we also armed what
the same thing and then I'm gonna talk a
little bit about our experience dealing
with typescript so I get this wonderful
piece of code here it's currently just
normal JavaScript right and we can study
the code but we don't really know what
it does right we can just type anything
and our editor notice that there is a
thing called sort people but that's
about it I can right now write anything
here and you know who knows what it's
going on because in the end of stress or
JavaScript and if it blows up it's gonna
do so at runtime between now and running
it there's nothing that's going to
verify that this code is correct right
and the interesting part is that if I
want to turn this into typescript which
was the case for the stack application I
can just start by renaming the file and
in the beginning nothing really happens
because javascript is relative script
and this is fine
and if you're looking at like 300 files
and you've got you know bugs to fix and
features to ship eventually this is
amazing this is fantastic
if you talk briefly about CoffeeScript I
don't really have many opinions about
CoffeeScript but the whole notion that
CoffeeScript was so drastically
different from JavaScript was sort of
always a non-starter for me because I
never really stopped with nothing right
there's always like something that I'm
used to and the other thing that we're
noticing is that typescript is
immediately trying to help me a little
bit um if you can't see it that's like a
little arrow down here but it's saying
you can't just call this with the five
because you're setting the input right
here the parameter to an array so we're
gonna assume that you want an array
right and it's immediately saying hey
you probably can't do that just so you
know and even if I have like little
misspellings in my code right right now
I don't but with normal JavaScript this
would be a thing that is like really
easy to miss right here and I'm gonna
show you in a second how types critters
gonna find that so this by itself
already runs this is fine right and if I
look at something like like this result
right here
typescript already knows that this is an
array I didn't really have to do
anything so if I want to check out what
I can do with the result now typescript
already knows it knows all the methods
and knows all those methods work right
with all the various overloads and if we
look at the definitions for that we can
actually see what that looks like
typescript has this concept of
definition files and it ships with quite
a few quite a few big ones and this one
is just the one for normal JavaScript
just normal boring es6 it's like a
casual 21 thousand lines of definitions
which right now if you're a JavaScript
developer you sort of expected you just
know this right like you'd expect it to
know what kind of methods an array has
available and how you use them
you know how they all work together and
what the overloads are so that's
something that's just supposed to be in
your head but right now at least for me
as soon as I turned this into touch good
file I don't really need to because my
editor already knows and this is by the
way not Visual Studio code specific this
works with any editor because it just
hypes group in the back that has this
information can service it to any editor
and the other thing is now that I turned
this into typescript file I can
initialize this project as a typescript
project which religious means that we
have this T is config right here which
specifies what our target is right now
is five and then I can start the whole
compiler in watch mode which is exactly
what you would expect it to be it will
just try to take this code and turn it
into something useful something along
the lines of JavaScript and if I open up
this javascript file let me just do this
like side by side
the interesting part here is that this
JavaScript doesn't really do anything
specific right this is like sort of the
JavaScript I would have written if I
didn't have time script and this is for
me at least a really really big deal
this notion that there is no black magic
it's not like I open up this file and I
have no idea what it's coming from and
with so many compiled quote/unquote
compiled JavaScript files very often to
open them up and like I have no idea if
this is good code or not because that's
all on one line it looks terrible this
really helps right but let's keep going
a little bit we can now declare our
attempt a little right I can just say
hey this one people seems to be starting
some some type of person let me just get
rid of this I can just say what if we
went ahead and defined an interface and
to face person and this person interface
has a name and it has an age which is a
number right and then you can say this
input is actually an array of person
there we go now I can save this and one
thing happens immediately right now it
can't compile this file because as you
remember just like misspelled this local
compare and the reason it can't compile
right now is because typescript now has
like this nested information about my
types all right I'm doing the sort here
meaning that typescript will show you
this in the autocomplete already knows
what kind of information that can expect
right and notice that both a and B are
person and it knows what kind of
properties are available on a person
which is might notice that name is a
string and which is why I noticed that I
have locale compared with an e available
to me but not the one without and that's
a mistake that at least for me as a
JavaScript developer in the past was
really common like this happened to me
all the time right like these little
mini typos that I would eventually find
at runtime or like unit testing but I
would certainly not find them in my
editor and I didn't have the confidence
right now in my editor that this is
valid code
so that's pretty cool but the other
thing that's pretty cool is that if you
look at this transcript right here
things still haven't changed right the
types of just being stripped out they're
just not there and of course you can
sort of go beyond that a little bit
right if you want to you can just say
hey I want my type script to compile my
JavaScript a little bit and in fact you
can see that I'm using an arrow function
right here and sort that is turns into a
function here right but if I just change
that real quick from E is 5 to es6 I'm
going to go ahead and just like that we
have the arrow function back right and I
could define a thing like I could say I
don't know class person manager god
knows what there's a strike I could just
say a constructor would say I don't know
this hello equals foo this is not really
an out I'm gonna say hello it's a string
right here cool and you can now see that
we basically have some pretty simple
JavaScript but if I go back into my TSP
fake and change that to es 5 typescript
will again roughly write the JavaScript
I would have written in their target
language anyway it's pretty neat that's
pretty cool that is basically the demo
portion of this presentation it's
basically to point out that typescript
is really lightweight just what I like
about it but at the same time really
strong and extensible if I want to have
some cool features I want to use async
await it can do that if I want to have
classes with public and private
properties and can do that and if I want
to require some things that are not my
own stuff I can also do that right like
the typical example as always the pass a
cons for
sorry Const the quest equals require
request curly doesn't know that this is
an old thing right because I don't have
a package so Jason or no types installed
but I could just go ahead and if I had
internet right now I could just say NPM
install types request and that would
immediately fix the issue and that is
the case for like pretty much anything
that is available NPM so demo done
talking a little bit about more what
that means for us so what that means for
us right
so the first thing is that we could just
turn on on our giant JavaScript code
base we could just turn on the
typescript compiler I didn t have to do
anything else right we just like threw
it in there more like well I guess we're
gonna run this now every single time we
save code and it really found like a few
little errors which was cool
terrifying but it was cool you know
because in those places where typescript
can sort of verify some of the basic
properties of your code where it like
knows hey this thing should have a
property called like hello but you
actually misspelled that I already found
all these like little tiny structural
errors that really only happen if you
encapsulate like 50 different promises
and they all return something else and
at some point somebody forgot what the
original object would like and like a
tiny mistake and then somebody else
copied that and you all roughly know the
story right so we immediately turned it
on found some tiny bugs right away
didn't even do anything yet right and
then our initial plan was that we would
just start typing new files in
typescript that was the general idea we
wanted to just like try this on new
files and then see how it goes and
because we had slack we really strongly
believe in like checking our code over
and over and over again and basically by
the time we're done we like throw it all
away and try it again right this all
iterative gentleman we were expecting
that over time typescript will just take
over but what happens almost right away
is that working with JavaScript files
felt a little bit dirty like immediately
right happens very quickly and one thing
I personally I think my whole team
really underestimated is the power of
autocomplete everyone who ever worked in
Eclipse and visual studio will be like
you know duh of course it's cool but
it's really quite powerful to not have
to like check what is available on an
object every single time it's like
really nice right because every now and
then you're dropped into a project and
it's using I don't know not your
favorite front-end framework but
something else
it knows tried skip knows right and in
the case for me for instance like I
recently started opt-in Khoa and I
didn't open the documentation a single
time because I didn't have to not
because I knew anything about color but
because typescript did and that was good
enough right and that's pretty amazing
it's pretty outstanding so right away as
soon as we open up a javascript file
were just like grows I don't know
anything about this gotta open up the
documentation and if akuma code I don't
really know anything about it so
immediately you have this like very
quick incentive where every single time
you touched another JavaScript father
like I'm just gonna quickly pour this
over to type so it's gonna take a minute
and if you just go with like the basic
types and you don't add any of the super
fancy features that is very simple to do
it takes you a minute so what happened
is that instead of like slowly waiting
years for the whole code base so like
turn into typescript it took a few
months and at some point I became very
quickly we celebrated the last jobs
could file to be dead and immediately
one was typescript from the whole
codebase a pretty cool moment and then
the other thing is that if you run
typescript at commit time you gain this
like giant amount of confidence that you
didn't have before I hope that we're all
using some kind of Jesus so many people
welcome I can barely see anything
because the lights are so bright I just
see like this stream of people coming in
so anyway committing with confidence um
if you're the the the notion hopefully
some of you are using slack I hope so
because that's a company I work for but
if some of you are using slack the idea
that you can't use slack as what keeps
me up at night right that is my fear my
fear is that I wake up one morning and
what somebody's like oh did you know
that nobody could use slack last night
that is like my biggest fear so being
able to run typescript every single time
I commit anything and knowing that my
code is structurally sound it might
still be garbage code right but at least
it's structurally sound all the things
that call each other sort of fit
together
it's like Lego you can build all kinds
of turrets with Lego but at least think
I'm not gonna fall apart right which is
a good feeling that is extremely
powerful which also brings me to my
first downside there's a thing called TS
lint and I'm very happy for the people
that work emptiest lint because we
didn't work on it and it's pretty good
but it doesn't even come close to the
amazingness this is limbed Uslan can do
all kinds of magical things I don't know
if any of you are using it but whatever
dumb idea you might have in your team
about a thing you want to enforce these
lint will do it for you right which is
amazing right it's like if you if you
want like certain variables that declare
certain things always would be like
prepended with a certain emoji year's
Lynde will do that
ts linville not Tizen is like pretty
bare-bones and it uses like all the ESL
and basic features but extending it is a
little bit harder so look as we like
poured it some things over we had to let
go of some eastland configurations and
just try to find like ways around it but
it was still pretty good and then and I
think this is honestly the biggest
downside of typescript is so I used to
be a native developer and my whole
team's filled with native developers but
these days especially when you try to
hire for JavaScript is ich ins very
often you will encounter people who have
never seen a typed language they have
never worked in Visual Studio and never
worked in eclipse they have never
written anything like C++ and the whole
notion of some of the more advanced
features of typescript you know things
like interfaces and types that extend
themselves generics union types that
kind of stuff this doesn't mean anything
to you right now it's because you work
in JavaScript you didn't have to and
that's great and perfect but this can
mean that we are basically paying this
little tax off whenever we want to
introduce a more junior developer a more
JavaScript focus developer into our code
base we sort of need to like educate
them about these two basic things at
these like basic what is an interface
what is a union type what does it mean
if there's like it takes tens K right
and every now and then we come up with
these x2 / cool constructs or things we
can do in typescript and then the
response is that it's really cool but
also unreadable what nobody knows what
that does which is you know one of the
issues like we all really like jobs good
because it's so lightweight and so quick
and so cool and if you use typescript if
it's fullest extent it has like all this
fluff around it which I enjoy because it
keeps me confident and sleeping sound at
night but if you want to want to have
your code available for a bunch of
people out there that you hope are gonna
contribute to your code it's a little
bit harder right which is why I don't
know and then you will still see me in
like currently building a new project in
the node foundation called the electron
installer and for that we using standard
is mostly because I think it's easier
for everyone to contribute and we don't
have to you don't need to learn anything
in order to then jump into the code base
but right now if you want to work on the
slack desktop app you first get a basic
course and you know typed languages and
what union types are just kind of nice
so in summary talk was pretty short but
that's already it if you have any
questions you can find me at Felix dot
fun which is by the way great he LD
recommend that everybody goes and buys
adult fun domain it is extremely cheap
and if you have a complicated last name
like me it is amazing okay we got about
three minutes for questions if anyone
has any